alright this week's classic interview
this has been requested by many many
people a lot of people saying David you
know with someone like Donald Trump
running for president you should really
interview John Perkins the guy who wrote
tales of an economic hitman because it
is so relevant in thinking about how
Donald Trump sees the economy as
something to be used for his gain in his
gain at the exclusion of the gain of
others and it actually turns out we
interviewed John Perkins a couple of
years ago so we will go to my interview
from March twelfth of 2014 with John
Perkins uh about his work as an economic
hitman take a look I'm joined today by
John Perkins he's the author of
hoodwinked and also confessions of an
economic hitman he describes himself as
an ex economic hitman and also claims to
have played a role in the process of
economic colonization of third world
countries John it's really a pleasure to
speak with you I find your background so
interesting why don't we just to give
the audience who may not yet be familiar
with you a little bit of sense of your
background give us your background as an
economic hitman and what that means all
right David thank you yeah my official
title was chief economist at a major
consulting firm out of Boston I had
several dozen employees working for me
our job was really to identify countries
that have resources our corporations
covet like oil and arrange huge loans to
that country from the World Bank or its
sister organizations but the money never
actually went to the country instead it
went to our own corporations to build
infrastructure projects in that country
they made a great deal of profit from
that also some of the wealthier people
benefited from these projects things
like electric systems industrial parks
highways things that benefit very
wealthy families but don't help the
majority of the people who are too poor
to buy electricity in BK any jobs
industrial parks they don't hire many
people yet the country would be left
holding a huge debt they couldn't repay
and so at some point we'd go back and
say hey you know since you can't pay
your debts sell your resource oil
whatever very cheap to our companies
without any environmental restrictions
of social right
relations or privatized your public
sector businesses sell them real cheap
your utility companies your water and
sewage system your school's your jails
off to our corporations and in that way
we really created the world's first
truly global empire primarily without
the use of the military so you're really
talking about so many yet you were
directly exposed in other words to so
many of the issues we talked about in
this program and that corporate media
often ignores which are corporate
control over the commons the
privatization of public goods and
resources and so many of these other
things but at a certain point did you
have some kind of a realization that
what you were helping to achieve was a
negative thing or how did you transition
out of that world well it's a very
interesting system David because in fact
in business school I was taught that
that's exactly what you should do if you
want to help a developing country it
grow its economy you invest billions of
dollars in infrastructure and
statistically we can show that that
works the economy increases but it as I
get deeper and deeper into this and
perhaps because I'd been a Peace Corps
volunteer before that's living with very
poor people in Ecuador I I came to
understand that the poor people were not
benefiting that the statistics reflected
the very wealthy which is true in this
country to we know that 85 people
control more resources than half the
world's population our statistics are
very very skewed to those rich people so
I very quickly began to or they
shouldn't say very quickly took me a bit
of time but I just kept it I discovered
that you know our mission of helping the
poorest of the poor was not working we
were doing exactly the opposite we were
helping the wealthiest of the wealthy so
how did you what did you do you quit
your job certainly but how what
activists role did you take well I first
started to write a book which we
eventually would become concessions that
I contacted other economic hitman and
jackals jackals are the people that go
in if the economic hit men fail and
assassinate or overthrow presidents I'd
seen this happen with two of my clients
democratically elected president of
Ecuador highly role dost and the
president of Panama Omar Torrijos they
did not buy the system they didn't
listen to me and they were both
assassinated so I quit my job I started
writing
contacting these people and I
immediately get serious threats on my
life life and my young daughters life
the same time I was offered a job I
saying it to dinner by the chair of the
board of stone and Webster another major
big consulting firm he said hey you got
a great resume idea I've been chief
economist of his rival he said we'd like
to use your resume our proposals you
won't have to do any work for us and
we'd like to pay your half a million
dollar consultants retainer I just don't
write the book so here ya know that
that's it so then now we're kind of
transitioning into the other thing I
want to talk about and I want to be very
clear i highly recommend everybody read
your book Confessions of an economic
hitman they can also read hoodwink but
really we're talking about a lot of the
stuff from confessions not everything
you've said has has avoided scrutiny in
controversy and I would love to get your
reactions to some of the claims that are
made by by state department releases
which say that parts of your book not
insignificant parts are quote total
fabrications that your allegations about
for example the NSA's involvement in
economic policy is just completely made
up you know that you've been scrutinized
significantly now the obvious the easy
way to counter this would be for you to
say well of course they're going to say
that because they don't want the truth
getting out and to me I hope we can move
past that kind of obvious rebuttal and
really get your thoughts about what the
reaction has been from the State
Department too much much of what you've
written let me first start by saying
that the New York Times did a major
front page of the financial section a
sunday sunday times on on the book and
they they vetted it very very strongly
and came to the conclusion that it was
it was truthful the State Department I
found out why they created a block or
rather at that time a website called the
misinformation website and my book was
the only thing on it and it was puzzling
to me because it's it sold a lot of
copies of the book for me and they did
they made the allegation that I claim
that I've been recruited by the National
Security Agency which I was and that
that was ridiculous because the National
Security Agency only does cryptography
encoding and decoding messages well even
back then into
thousand five or so we all knew that NSA
did more than that and now especially we
certainly know that they that they do
more than that what were the
circumstances of this recruitment
attempt uh well first of all I was
married to a woman whose father was very
high up in the Department of the Navy in
Washington one of his best friend's was
high up in the national security agency
I was looking for a job that would keep
me out of Vietnam and so he arranged for
me to be interviewed by the NSA that
would do it and they put me through
extensive testing days of psychological
testing including lie detector tests and
concluded that I would make a good
economic hitman what I'm interested in
this what other kind of psychological
tests did they put you through father
were written tests there were interviews
there were lie detector tests that's
about it you know I mean you know I was
in a in a room by myself with lots of
desk right you know writing this thing
with books around me I'm sure their
cameras watching me you know the whole
the whole routine okay so so that that
one side of it the other thing and i'll
just ask you directly the state
department claims that you believe the
government was complicit in the
assassinations of JFK robert f kennedy
martin luther king john lennon and
unnamed US senators who have died in
plane crashes is that something you
allege no it's not I've never alleged
that I I probably opened the question as
to whether it it might have had been
that way what I have alleged though is
that we were involved in the
assassination of jaime roldos that
Ecuador and omar torrijos at panama
because i was there i know we've
admitted that we were that we took out a
n day in Chile Henry Kissinger has
admitted it in and our bins and wat
amala and Lumumba and diem and mostly
deck in Iran we've admitted to many many
of these things and I also wanted to go
back Dave David for just a moment to to
the State Department I think I always
wondered why they did that website
because it sold a lot of books for me
and I found out later through through
a good friend who is also a host of the
major show in Athens who did a show on
name was called in to the Athens Greece
US embassy called on the carpet for
doing that show and the ambassador said
it puts me in a very embarrassing
position because people come in and ask
me is Perkins book real is it is what
does our fit what is your official
position on he said I don't have one I
don't what to say well I believe that a
lot of diplomats around the world where
asked that question so the State
Department felt that it had to come out
with an official statement that negated
the book and that's why they did what
they did and they'd get their their
diplomats off the hook they could just
say hey the official position is on is
on our website don't ask me any more
about it and it sold a lot of books for
me very quickly just in the last minute
we have left here I would love to just
get your opinion on when you look at the
United States right now and the
influence that big corporations and big
banks have over every everybody's
everyday lives in terms of the political
system the economic system resources etc
what's your biggest concern in other
words in which area do you think were
closest to the tipping point for things
really taking a turn for the worst well
I think what we know is we've created a
death economy one that's based on
killing people militarization and
ravaging the earth we need to move into
a life economy that's based on cleaning
up pollution feeding starving people
developing new technologies for
transportation communications energy etc
and we've been moving more and more in a
very bad direction we've created an
economy and global economy that's an
adjective less than five percent of us
live in the United States we consume
almost thirty percent of the world's
resources while half the world starving
that's not a model can't be repeated by
China even though they're trying it just
puts the world at a worse skin condition
when other countries try to repeat our
model we must come up with a new model
and I and I think that corporations that
heads of corporations that are really
smart or understanding this I recently
was invited to be the leadoff keynote
speaker at a conference of 2000 business
executives in Istanbul I get those
invitations fairly frequently I think
business is beginning to get it I think
consumers the beginning to get it I
think we're truly in a consciousness
revolution a huge revolution where
people are waking up to the fact that
we're live
a very fragile spatialization that has
no shuttles we're going to have to take
care of this place and big business is
going to have to play a major role in
waking up and taking care of the serving
a public interest not the one percent
but the ninety-nine percent serving the
earth in essence and we all need to get
out there and make sure that happens
we've been speaking with John Perkins
the books are hoodwinked and confessions
of an economic hitman really great to
have you on I do appreciate it thank you
David and I'd like to encourage people
to go to John Perkins door and org and
sign up for my newsletter and see where
I'm going to be speaking so I can meet
them personally